well here's something for the ladies who
are just special Maxim and Val you know
the hot brothers from Dancing with the
Stars they are launching a show that is
part dancing and part bio as they lay
out their lives bare and I mean we do me
bare yeah but here's my problem why
can't these guys just ever put a shirt
off wife that day anyway Samantha Harris
had a chance to sit down with them and
talk about their love lives now that you
re officially a taken man yes people
still have a chance with you I don't
know if you're dating anyone I'm single
yes ladies val is free but max is
happily engaged to be on tape Tina
Murgatroyd and planning the proposal
seems to have taken a lot out of him
your wedding plan I've done my part
you know is what I'm saying I just want
a year break from happy Amy to plan
anything this is your best man obviously
but here's why we were with the guys
they're hitting the road with their mats
and Val our way to her this summer
tickets go on sale today we're gonna
tour we even same to us we tell you this
out I mean honestly we we have
separation anxiety disorder probably
we've bunkbed it so literally like 18
and 20 phrase yeah their show will be a
combination of dance and a play about
their lives from Ukraine to Hollywood I
mean this is the American dream like we
two to two kids that immigrated to
Brooklyn New York
ballroom dancing
I'm longtime friends with these two but
things got a little weird when the
conversation somehow turn to kissing
describe how you kiss kissing is like
hugging with your lips it's not a
physical action okay hope let me just I
love you so much on it one mouth much
okay I'm ready yes the entitlement it
doesn't work like that
it just it has to happen and if your bad
kisser just go practice well nobody's
heard any complaining for PETA so you
must be doing a-okay Mack